for eight seasons between 1991 and 1999
Tim the Tool Man Taylor could count on
his nextdoor neighbor Wilson to offer
him sage and amazingly specific advice
on the hit ABC sitcom Home
Improvement is there anything you don't
know
Wilson I don't
know over the course of the series it
was revealed that Wilson's full name was
Wilson W Wilson and that he had been
married but lost his wife he was highly
educated well read had traveled
extensively and he may or may not have
been the cousin of Dennis and Brian
Wilson of The Beach Boys the audience
mostly just saw the top half of Wilson's
head as his face always was behind the
privacy fence separating his yard from
the tailor and though there were plenty
of other shots the audience never saw
Wilson's entire face at once the running
gag evolved in Home Improvements later
years with Wilson a occasionally
venturing beyond the fence only for the
bottom part of his face to still be
hidden through some convoluted means
while the joke was inspired fans have
long wondered why this Choice was made
it's a strange choice and outlandish fan
theories went wild one Theory suggests
that Wilson won't show his face because
he's in the witness protection program
and continues to suggest that his wife
was killed by the mob another bizarre
and kind of gross theory supposes that
we never see Wilson's face because he's
the biological father of one of Tim's
children and Wilson doesn't want the
kids to notice that they kind of look
like him the real answer about Wilson's
hidden face is surprisingly simple as a
child Tim Allen would hold regular
conversations with his nextdoor neighbor
through a fence since Allan was only a
small kid at the time all he could ever
see was the top of his neighbor's head
this made a pretty strong impression on
the young Allen and went on to be the
inspiration that would one day hands an
amazing character actor his signature
raw as for actor Earl Hinman his full
face can be witnessed in a number of
Great Performances throughout his career
before his passing in 2003 Earl Heyman
was featured prominently in a number of
films and TV shows throughout the 70s
and 80s he's likely best known to
viewers from that era as Lieutenant Bob
Reed on the ABC soap opera Ryan's Hope
in which he appeared in over 500
episodes across 13 seasons on film
hinman's exploits were even more
thrilling in the western Silverado
Heyman played JT opposite Patricia Gul
as Kate 10 years earlier in the Parallax
view he played the antagonistic Deputy
red arguably his greatest turn can be
seen in the critically acclaimed 1974
crime Thriller the taking of pelum 123
in which Hinman stars as the Dastardly
and enigmatic train hijacker Mr Brown
Home Improvement was one of the final
project Hyman had the chance to work on
before his death he left an indelible
mark on the series's many fans in 2011
Tim Allen began starring in a new
television project with a similar vibe
to Home Improvement titled Last Man
Standing the series follows a marketing
director for a large outdoor and
Sporting Goods chain as he navigates
life as the last man among his wife and
three daughters the series ran for nine
seasons and in its final season Allan
bent the boundaries of his Universe to
pay tribute to Earl heyman's Wilson in
The Last Man Standing episode dual time
Allan does double duty for the first
time since the Santa Claus 2 in order to
finally deliver on the Home Improvement
in Last Man Standing crossover fans
wanted as Allen's Tim Taylor opens up to
Allan's Mike Baxter a serendipitous
facial cover divider reminds the former
of his friend and neighbor Wilson whom
Tim confirms passed away in the years
since Home Improvements
end
always find it easier to open up when
I'm just talking to the top half of
another man's
face